when I started my journey and people
started calling me the Dog Whisperer the
only thing I wanted to do is to teach
people there is no such a thing as a bad
dog oh my God
keep it with me
today I'm still doing what I love but
the pandemic has changed the world
[Music]
religions have hit a record high the
things as dog shelters are empty the bad
news is people
Steelers
help he doesn't listen to me like the
problem is me what do I do more pushes
more problems right this is why he
doesn't listen to you so many things you
can fix already
the excitement I just want you to get
fit do you know who I am together with
My Superhero pack our mission is to
Teach the World to honor the pack code
honesty integrity and loyalty once you
get this you're gonna have everything
else and that's how we create better
humans and better dogs one pack at a
time
when a dog growls barks even by people
that's serious it's serious it
terrorizes people it terrifies people
but when a dog kill another dog they're
just be on
anything you can explain anything you
can say anything you can label this this
is to me the worst Red Zone
very serious and very sad
I'm on my way to meet a family in
distress
this family absolutely need help ASAP
they need help yesterday and I wasn't
there yesterday so I'm gonna be there
today and allow them to see the future
it's a life or death mission to help a
Red Zone dog who began attacking members
of her own pack the family made a
desperate plea in hopes of keeping the
dog a part of their family
oh
hi I'm Sophia I'm the mom no hi I'm
Kaylee I'm the youngest sister I'm Megan
I'm the middle sister
um and we we're the Thompson the
Thompsons
each of my girls have a dog I have a dog
we have a family dog we have lots of
dogs there's Nyla Nyla is just this big
ball of energy goob he really takes
after the name that I gave him which is
goober he's just a big goofball along
with Finn miso and Cody
I think amongst the dogs they all have
their own quirks but they're all
neurotic
relax we have little dogs and nyla's our
biggest dog Nyla used to be able to hang
out with the other dogs not anymore that
would be a blood bath don't put your
hand in front of her mouth
they just don't get along
I do not walk Milo with any other dog to
keep all the dogs separate
when we feed the dogs each room is like
separated with baby gates
Papa has to eat in the kitchen goop how
to eat in his crate and then miso Finn
and Cody have to eat in the living room
if any little mistake happens everything
can go wrong oh it's so stressful I'm
shaking we thrive on it no we don't
thread on it
all the dogs multiple times just got
worse and worse and worse
so my last dog his name was chiquito
he was a little toy chihuahua
I I was there when Nyla ended up killing
chiquito
when I found out the news that Nyla
killed Chiquito I was completely in
shock
I rushed home
to find my daughter holding her dog's
lifeless body
I didn't even know what I could do for
her it was very devastating
in our hearts we love Nyla
but I really don't want her hurting
someone else
I mean the worst case scenario for us is
that if she doesn't get better Nyla
could kill him again
and then we could have to put Nyla down
to assess Nyla Caesar needs to see the
entire pack in their natural habitat at
home with the Thompsons
come over here come over here yes a lot
of female power in this house
I'll see I grew up with three sisters go
inside you guys are like the Kardashians
you guys have a very chaotic environment
and that's what we don't want that's
what we have exactly yeah I see a worry
faces all along all the three ladies the
whole body language is you know
concerned worry because they're
frustrated because they've been living
this way for a long time so you got a
layer of worry a little bit of
frustration a layer of feeling guilty
so can you tell me about the dog that
got killed what was his name Chiquito
she said get up yeah you would have
loved him you're so cute oh my God
she was also very quiet just like her
she's just very like her
what happened was they were eating and
we usually separate them when they're
eating my dog Chiquito He Slipped
through the gate and he went towards
nyla's food and then Nyla just like
snapped at him
um and she let go pretty quickly but she
did puncture him and she just
passed away
sorry to hear that Chiquito he was the
sweetest dog anybody will ever meet like
the one dog that meant so much to me
because typically dogs don't like me so
it was refreshing to have one dog who
like adored me and just seeing him pass
away like that is it's very traumatizing
[Music]
here's a video from the other day we
caught on the security cameras
so that's Nyla in the front right there
that's my mom
she actually like attacked me wait wait
okay right there it's pretty bad
one fatal attack is bad enough but now
this is a pattern of violence this
family is already carrying a lot of
guilt if Nyla kills again they might put
her down and that will crush them and I
can't let that happen you want to meet
Nyla right now yeah I would like to meet
her out here yeah
you ever see me smiling and making jokes
just because it's very serious and I'm
looking at Sophia just completely
shrinking and becoming a rock
come here
just open the door just let him meet up
are you sure yes just open the door
her like just going through you yeah
yeah there you go oh wow when I saw
Caesar correct her behavior that was
like wow it actually can happen I wonder
if we can do it right now I have a lot
of anxiety because I don't know what
she's gonna do but she looks so happy
and calm you just have to that's what I
would like to show you and because you
have no clue yes you know on the how do
dogs speak
because I wish she was barking she was
happy but you have to learn to recognize
that so you nurture that and you trust
that remember she's a Hound she's gonna
pick up on a sand she's gonna alert
always
that's what she's doing right now she's
sniffing okay you understand but she's
using her nose yeah we've been teaching
her to go
laughs
I got it I got it I just want you to get
bit
oh I don't know
do you know who I am yeah
so right now she was entering into a
fight mode that's what we got to
take care of when Nyla first came out
she had a happy bark but I could hear a
shift into an agitated bar as she began
to focus on my camera guy I could tell
she was about to buy so I immediately
needed to snap her out of it
all right so maybe we don't bring my
girl right now but I want to see your
skills on walking with the dogs I want
to see you guys in action Pinella
they want to see the dogs on the wall
because it gives me a way more insight
about the whole family Nyla can be
walked safely with the other dog so
we're going to leave her at home who's
the best cook because that's what I work
for I work for food how do dogs behave
outside how much of connection
communication
[Music]
that's going to tell me the skills they
have
so when was the last time Nyla did this
parade with all of that yeah for a long
time like how long like like two to
three years yeah we can we can't because
what happens is Nyla lunges at bicycles
so it's very stressful walking her
she's like a gang member
yeah
oh my God
we were walking after less than one
block I had to stop it this is way too
out of control somebody's gonna get bit
or pull in front of a moving car all
right that's it you know that Thompson's
called me for Nyla but the problem is
much bigger all of this chaos including
nyla's aggression is in response to the
Thompson frantic communication and
nervous energy one dog is already dead
if something doesn't change it's not if
but when Nyla will kill again
I got you
the next day Sophia Megan and Kaylee
arrive at the ranch
welcome to the dog Psychology Center for
the first day of work with Nyla and the
rest of the pack
how the Thompson dogs behave up close
with new dogs
I spent years training my pack how to
safely be around aggressive animals so
there'll never be In Harm's Way We Know
nyla's had the most serious issues so I
wanted to start with her first Andre you
come up and supervise okay
she has to be super calm
see this is really good going all the
way to a camp surrender state
three
[Music]
three all right
by Nyla not showing any aggression she's
telling me she's comfortable with my
package I'm going to let her in but I'll
keep her on a short leash
extremely nervous
I was just scared that Nyla would attack
one of them I didn't trust her at all
this is the respond that I want
he's actually surrendering it's
beautiful that's good what do you think
I'm scared you're scared yeah your whole
family is scared your last name right
now is fear
that was very interesting I didn't see
any aggression from Nyla even though
she's the one who's supposed to be on a
hair trigger
now I want to see the other four dogs
react to my back without Nyla around
it looks like the group is very chaotic
very frantic
goob the Beagle mix doesn't have nyla's
History of Violence but now he's showing
over-excited aggression Caesar splits
him off to see how he reacts to the pack
first
hey
close the door hey
so if he goes we have to address it and
let him know that that's not allow so
this guys on the other hand this is like
your cheerleaders yeah that's pretty
much all they're doing because watch
what happens when they're in there
they mean no harm
so what happened right now why I let
these guys go because this these guys
are just
ah they're just imitating what's
happening in your house
yeah because they're fine I've never
seen them like this
Cody doesn't care about anything who
Cody oh the one in the blue harness he
just does not care he does he cares in a
different way yeah all he wants to do is
explore
[Music]
hey
so you don't just have a problem with
Nala group is a big problem it's a big
problem
Caesar works with a family in disarray
hound mix Nyla fatally injured one
family dog and viciously attacked
another
but this morning it's goop that's
causing trouble
[Music]
oh my God
hey
I can tell the goop is a frantic
aggressive type
hey he sees the family is nervous and he
tries to protect them by attacking any
dog that approaches them hey
so you don't just have a problem with
Nala I don't think they realize the goop
is a big problem it's a big problem
Google can trigger the wrong energy so a
little dog can trigger a German Shepherd
to retaliate but they're going to blame
the German Shepherd because the German
Shepherd is going to punch harder yep so
I don't go and fight Mike Tyson
but right now nyla's responding way
better than goo
I've seen enough and honestly these two
dogs shouldn't go back home today just
taking a break from the family like I
would like to keep nalang group with me
without you guys influencing
Mama I'm gonna be a good girl okay
not gonna lie it made me really sad to
leave Nyla behind I know it's gonna be
good for her like that's not even a
doubt in my head but does it make me sad
yeah it does blind ugly ciao ladies
the next morning
Caesar begins his first exercise to
address Nyla and goob's aggression since
Nyla attacked Chiquito months ago she's
largely lived separately from the other
dogs including goop this is the first
time these guys have been together
without a gate in months to break this
pattern Caesar wants to forge a more
trusting bond between the two animals
see that movement that you make a little
tense and move back they're still not
trusting each other because that's
that's really the vibration that's in
the house they don't trust
I want to continue the shock Factor you
know this is what I'm doing I'm letting
my dogs running all at once before Nala
and goop can get comfortable with them
we're gonna see if the reaction how do
they gonna feel
it's a wave of dogs I mean who shock
them in a good healthy way I want him to
depend to each other I want to see we're
not familiar to this dog so let's just
work together
Nyla it's just chill relax that's really
good although Nyla is that he's around
the other dogs
remains aloof let's get goober in it
goop has it all backwards he deals with
the stress of these new dogs by putting
distance between them that's a
territorial behavior that leads to fight
when his face is invaded so I need to
eliminate his territorial mindset and
cause him closer to the rest of the pack
foreign
just like yesterday goo lashed out when
another dog knows into his territory
now that I corrected him I want to bring
him closer to the pack instead of
finding Comfort by claiming territory I
want him to find a familiar face Nyla so
she's adjusting way quicker than this
guy
so they can help each other with
attention
look at this
that was very cute you can see that
after he wasn't allowed to lash out good
luck to Nyla for Comfort I'll continue
to keep eye on goop's territory impulses
but since Nyla feeds off his energy a
calmer goop means a calmer Nyla this is
a huge first building block on the way
to recovery look the drinking work
together oh my God that's that the lady
in the Trump right there working
one-on-one with Caesar Nyla and goob
quickly show huge improvements but
Caesar notices around the Thompsons they
behave very differently feeding off the
family's chaotic energy
to be safe enough to send Nyla back into
the Thompson home Caesar needs the
family to address their issues head on
bring them in bring them in what group
and and Nyla are doing right now is
pretty spectacular can't wait
so I want you to breathe I want you to
relax
the Thompsons are caught in a vicious
cycle their anxiety makes nylon goof
aggressive which makes the whole family
even more anxious so I want to find out
when the worry first begin
so you guys are working together but
with a lot of fear
like Sophia is anything hold you back
so um
there was some domestic violence that's
going on when my ex was there and their
dad
all the dogs the saw the the turmoil and
all the chaos and
the bad things that happen in the house
what happened to you you get quieter
well it goes through you
I don't know I don't really express my
emotion
but what do you feel inside even if it
doesn't come out you're still feeling it
I'm angry yeah
makes sense
I know for Kaylee she didn't have the
physical
abuse from him but
the verbal and the emotional was really
bad
we all got these dogs because we all
needed the emotional support we use them
as a crutch
the dogs were
there for for us and when Chiquito
passed I didn't know how to deal with it
I just kind of put it aside I didn't
comfort her or I didn't know how to say
I'm sorry your dog passed and it was at
the hands of one of our other dogs
and that was something she loved so
deeply and all of us felt different
emotions and we pushed it all in because
we want to be strong we're really strong
women you felt that when you first came
and we are we are even feel myself
so our family has gone through a lot
yeah
thank you so much for sharing this is
part of what what I need to make sure
that I get so I know where you are you
know I know that the dogs are sensing
something I just didn't know what it was
this is really the first time that the
three of us have talked about it but
thanks for feeling safe with me
this pain goes so much steeper than I
realized I really understand that pain
because I have my own dark times but one
thing that helped me go through it is my
dogs
I always say dogs don't live in the past
they live in the present it's people
that live in the past the Thompsons need
to learn from their dogs and let go of
that past Caesar wants to keep Nyla and
goob overnight again to make sure they
don't backtrack
and the next day Sophie is back for a
one-on-one session welcome back thank
you to the ranch
I have few surprises for you okay I got
the call from Caesar that I'm supposed
to come by myself to the DPC and I don't
know what to expect so I'm definitely
very anxious and nervous about today
today's it's a very important day it's a
Sofia's day I'm a single dad as well I
take care of my boys and a lot of times
when we are the single parent all the
locals on us yes and sometimes we need a
little bit of help you know what I mean
I felt that I needed to show you all the
stuff that you're missing such as the
calmness
I wanted to invite her today because as
a single mom she's the pack leader but
right now she's an anxious pack leader
the girls and dogs are cute enough of
her energy Caesar wants to see how come
the dogs can remain when Sophia is in
their presence once more I had a girl I
had a girl oh my God I don't even know
it was my dog
then you're gonna go right there in the
middle okay Caesar has put so much time
in you see it what a change yeah the
most important thing is to be calm you
have to be very aware of myself and how
calm I am because if I'm anxious tense I
can undo all that progress remember stay
calm
Caesar works with Sophia whose coonhound
Nyla violently attacks other family dogs
fueled in part by the Frantic energy of
fellow pack member group then you're
gonna go right there in the middle away
from Sophia Nyla and goob forged a more
trusting Bond but their owner's arrival
is a big test of their progress if
you're nervous about it they feel it
okay
that's correction
that's you that's it that's all let's
correct then let's do it again
don't worry about it
Nyla goes back into protector Uber tried
to come back Nyla went right back and
nope I'm claiming her so nobody can come
in unless I decide that
we just have to bring it back that's it
that's right the brain is good well if
we get close to her we fight you know
what I mean so what they're doing is
fighting to protect you so you got to be
assertive and redirect before it
escalates but I'm glad that happened now
because I want nobody to get hurt but I
want you to see how I respond to that
come on Nyla must learn that she doesn't
need to protect Sophia from other dogs
to desensitize her I'm going to have
Sophia walkup what Nyla has to watch
just stay
pass me a leash
now you're gonna what you're gonna do
right now you're just gonna welcome up
with my boy right now just walk around
around her she can't move out of there
okay
stay
remind her that you have to stay stay
send it back there we go stay stay yes
stay
come back over here
you're gonna give affection here to my
boy the show now that it's okay that she
doesn't need to protect you
drop the leash
then come here
and give her give him affection that's
your mom dude
[Music]
that's right
you see what you did right there you're
showing leadership so they don't feel
how they don't have to worry about it
I'll say today was a good day good show
no aggression Nyla had one set back but
she ended up in a great note even more
important Sophia's beginning to
understand how to take control of her
anxiety what is different about you
right now I'm calm I don't feel tense
it's still early but improving the
Pack's energy is a big step it's
Sophia's day today all right guys come
in don't don't call him we just got
one dog killing another dog often ends
up with two victims when I talk with
owners whose dogs have acted out in such
a terrible way the vast majority feels
like they have to put their dog down
bear here with several people his family
even has scheduled an appointment to put
him down but like Nyla he got a death
row pardon Nala gets a second chance but
it's probably her last chance if she
kills again that Thompson said that they
will have to put her down I know how
much they love her so that will break
them I'm not even going to raise the
possibility with Sophia and the girls
they know that the stakes are high
instead we're gonna focus on making sure
that that's a decision the family never
have to make
Caesar's worked with nylon goob on the
ranch for two weeks and they've come a
long way
but Caesar is still concerned about one
area feeding time I have learned that
with Nala she gets very territorial
around food
it was during meal time that Nyla bit
and fatally injured Chiquito for the
Thompson ladies
food means somebody die so to get the
pack back they have to go through their
fears I'm gonna teach them how to
properly feed a pack of dogs yeah
feeding times get really chaotic because
we you know because of the incident that
happened with Chiquito we are just
afraid yeah since chiquito's death the
dogs all eat separately Nyla and goob in
the kitchen with goob inside a crate and
the other three dogs behind a gate in
the living room
the family does this because Nyla
attacks any dog that invades her space
during Phoenix
now let's do territorial you know which
is normal you can eat in a restaurant
and somebody comes and take the food
you're going to be territorial about it
you see it we protect our food we
protect our home we protect our family
but when you use too much for you can
hurt somebody severely this is what
happened I'm just going to show you how
I normally do it with her okay bring
some food let me go get her happy to be
home yeah first I'm going to show the
family the key ideas for feeding Isla
around other dogs then they'll go inside
and feed them while I watch from out
here I want to see how they communicate
and work together okay so here we have
to make sure that
she doesn't get too excited because she
loves food she's a foodie like me what's
very important is as soon as it's
fitting time she should be the one in
the back and she should be the last one
to be fat it's very important that she
is the most well-behaved of all
especially in feeding time when we put
Nala's Bowl down what prevents thin miso
goob and Cody from approaching her dish
but you can always tie them down you
know that's always an option that's so
when we're feeding them we should be
leashing them all up yeah
this is the first time since shikito was
killed the Nyla will be eating around
the other dogs so the family's
communication and energy has to be spot
on
they need to each have their own task
and execute the plant silently if not
things could get dangerous really fast
stay quiet because the excitement of the
food is already plenty and then each one
I want to take care of two dogs Kylie
you're going to take care of these two
dogs and you're going to take care of
these two dogs you're gonna take care of
Nala and the food preparation I don't
want to influence anything so I'm just
going to stay right here I'm gonna watch
you guys from here so if you're doing
something they're not supposed to I'll
let you know okay go Cody Cody
so how are we gonna do this
[Music]
you know got it you're not helping me I
can't I'm one person I can't do this all
for myself
hey she's getting excited
guys stop stop somebody's gonna get hurt
I'm gonna watch you guys from here
Caesar is working with a family whose
anxiety and poor communication is
creating chaos among their five dogs
chaos that led to coonhound Nyla
accidentally killing another family dog
the incident happened at meal time I
don't like doing them together like this
Sophia and her daughters can't learn to
feed their dogs safely Caesar won't be
able to return Nyla to the home
hey hey she's getting excited
hey guys stop stop stop somebody's gonna
get hurt tighten all it down and come
out here
my God
did you did you uh did you understand
what you did in there because you saw
what how you guys were communicating
yes it was this yeah it was just like a
lot of talking over each other and this
is
you know what I mean it's really fast
it's really chaotic it gives me anxiety
when my mom's yelling at me yeah yeah
and I'm very anxious because nobody's
doing what they're supposed to do they
didn't do the two most important things
I told them they need to talk less and
when they do is speak in a calm way and
they need to stick to the plan who's
feeding which dog so there is less chaos
in the moment
all right let's do it can we try it
again okay yeah let's go
way better see the difference already
yeah I don't know I'm still kind of
anxious yeah listen deal with your
anxiety it's just it's not coming out as
a sound
much better they're feeling nervous in
the feeling anxious and all of that
stuff but at least they can deal with
that better versus they want to do it
fast you know the fact the more they
talk the faster they move
if I look at the difference now
[Music]
it's perfect that's the word
seven yes
coming out ladies you're doing good I
was very nervous but actually seeing it
and doing it I know it's possible so I
know if we work on it we probably can do
it I'm happy that we were able to do it
today with your guidance so it was just
nice to see them all together eating
this was another important step in their
journey I am really proud of the
Thompsons facing their fears it wasn't
perfect but the family is putting the
trauma of chiquito's dead behind them
and making some big improvements in
their communication skills not bad right
did great I don't have any more worries
about goop he's been on his best
behavior for weeks so I'm going to leave
him here with the family but Nyla still
has more work to do so I need to bring
her back to the ranch
for over two weeks Caesar worked with
Nyla to eliminate the last remnants of
her aggressive impulses you gotta block
her
okay
there you go
all right we're probably gonna go a
little bit faster let's go girl this is
good for you we do this every day
this is good for you the work paid off
now she's consistently calm and
comfortable around Caesar and his other
animals
JJ look who's changing dude come on that
doesn't warm your heart however the
question is how she will behave when she
is once again around the Thompsons if
they don't improve their energy and
communication it could send Nyla right
back to square one this is ranch life
so the purpose of the next activity is
just to continue trusting our dogs and
more than anything is for you girls to
practice the calmness hopefully you grab
this all this memory that I'm giving you
the latest show calm communication
during the feeding exercise and their
home but I want to see if they can bring
those skills outside where there are a
lot more distractions and potential
triggers so we're gonna go in there see
this we're going to be your neighbors my
Barnyard pack are my best partners and
teaching and reinforcing good behavior
these animals are experts in handling
unruly dogs this is Marty
every animal here is rescue
you know they know how to stay calm and
my team and I always make sure they're
totally safe I am going to introduce the
family and their dogs to my barrier
animals and have Sophia lead the whole
pack on a walk so this is look this is
the equivalent of them going to
Disneyland
right so I'm gonna leave her with the
leash so here she goes it's easy for me
to grab it just in case so I place a
halter nyla's mouth which makes it
impossible for her to really bite down
because they're all going to come in
right now
all right let's get him out
that's good if they want to go that way
hey
the purpose of the next activity is for
you girls to practice the calmness Nyla
is a coonhound that attacks her fellow
family packmates after two weeks of
working with Caesar one-on-one at the
dog Center her aggression improved but
when around her family once more she
feeds off of their nervous energy at
attacks
so if you're going to say no no no it's
it's best to do something about it okay
what they're doing is protecting
creating a space right but then you have
the talent listen don't worry about it
we got it yeah we got this we have to
tell them hey we're fine don't worry
about it don't worry just keep going yes
that's right
we're gonna gather them and go and walk
in that direction all right we're gonna
go just one round lead the pack ma'am
I follow you
cat you guys keep on everything
if he doesn't like move forward you can
just tap them yep
keep moving forward
hey there you go
hey hey nice
they're following your mom I know she's
a leader yep it's awesome to see Sophia
really stepping into her role as family
pack leader look at that this is
beautiful no nice she's asserting
herself and managing all five dogs with
composure look look at that look at your
dogs
this lesson was another building block
for Nyla and the family she had a few
stumbles early today hey yes but by the
end Nyla was really taking Sophia's
Direction well and that is an experience
just to see as possible
and this guy is not trying to kill the
whole entire world yeah yeah thankfully
thankfully thank you for a great day
thank you thank you so much well today
was a huge success all right that's it
for you guys today I want to send the
Thompsons home so I can have one more
day with Nyla come on to finish our work
together
that's it very good
there you go
I see I can't surrender dog I see it the
redirection is working
there you go
sit
yeah
good so the safety the peace and the
calmness that this state of mind brings
that's beautiful
now she has a better chance to actually
go up there and and stay in their home
picture I know you just got blocked by a
donkey
today's a new day
four long weeks at the ranch
Caesar has transformed Nyla but for
Caesar to return Nyla to the Thompson
home the family must have the skills to
keep her from ever killing again
so he's heading back to the Thompsons
for a final challenge I'm gonna put him
in two different situations one is to do
the bike not a lot of response reacts to
the bike and we're gonna do the pack
walk in the neighborhood with all those
dogs this challenge is going to require
the ladies to put all the pieces
together from the past month I need the
girls to prove me that they can have the
backpack fingers crossed
[Music]
[Applause]
having our final challenge
so today I would like to see you guys
walking with the pack okay however now
you're in charge so just sit up in a
calm way okay you know how we're gonna
achieve this uh
last challenge you guys walk the little
dogs I'll take Nyla I'll take um
let's go
how does it feel walking down uh a
little scary but just breathe okay the
first challenge is for Sophia to learn
how to manage Nyla around bikes it's one
of the reasons they haven't been able to
walk her with the pack I made progress
in sensitizing her but the family will
have to continue this work at home I
want to start by seeing how Sofia does
using her new skills handling nylon I
know that Nyla has a reactivity towards
a bike so I want to challenge you we
have someone waiting over there with a
bike all right ladies just move to the
side
yes
all right Sebastian
oh my God
okay here you scared me
all right whenever you're ready bro
chaos in the Thompson families pack has
recently led to their coonhound Nyla
fatally biting another family dog
for Caesar to allow her back in the home
Sophia must show they can safely control
her and the rest of the pack
Sophia's fear and tension is triggering
Nyla as much as the bike is if she
relaxes and anticipates nyla's reaction
she'll be able to control her much
better that's the important thing do it
again
she keeps lunging relax relax
come on
she's not gonna do it there
[Music]
the ears are back and the head is low
we don't get tense look
to here
no tension on the leash if she looks
that's when you put the tension try it
again relax
hey okay
he told me to keep the leash loose and
as soon as I see her ears going forward
to correct her
that was good
yep
one more time we got Sophia in the zone
so I saw the bike corrector
finally that's good yeah it worked
being able to control Nyla with that
bike situation which is my biggest fear
gives me hope that I can definitely face
the other fears I have which are less
significant than this one yeah
now the family must control their pack
on a walk around the neighborhood a
final test of all the skills they've
learned over the last four weeks Sophia
hasn't walked Nyla with the other dogs
in over two years so this is a huge
moment for the family and the hall pack
I'm feeling very nervous I know we're
coming up towards some houses with some
crazy dogs I don't know how nyla's going
to react
so I keep telling myself to breathe
Slow Down slow down
okay that's good right there she's doing
it right there she's doing it she's
doing it she's doing it
be good yes
I love it I love it I love it yes
slow down
don't don't let it give you eye contact
yeah
absolutely yes
no that was really cool to watch like
she felt my energy I felt her relax my
arm relaxed
was loose and it like felt amazing I
want you guys to walk by
your mom is challenging you to take the
challenge good morning I want to cry
in my dogs all together beautiful
movement beautiful beautiful yes after
today I do not have a fear of walking
Nyla quicker boom
show what the quiet girl can do that's a
perfect state of mind if Nyla were to
attack another one of our dogs we would
not only be losing the dog that she hurt
but we would have to put her down but
now that Caesar came along and helped us
she can be able to stay in the house we
love her very much she's a great
companion she's a great dog so I'm
really happy and proud of her
I'm coming for your job now
[Laughter]
[Music]
there is times where I know that the
family has a lot on their shoulders this
is one of those families now you manage
in a pack
with calm confident
this family has grief and this family
has pain his family has confusion so I'm
very mindful of that you know not just
rehabilitating a dog that is aggressive
and a dog that is frantic I'm taking in
consideration all those layers of
emotions your dogs are doing incredible
I'm about to throw a party right now
this is one of those special cases that
I did a lot of praying a lot a lot of
brain
but it couldn't gotten any better than
this just perfect it's just perfection
my goal was to reunite the family and so
it went really well
[Music]